the jurgen experience what was your
experience like with the whole
snl debacle thing what was that like
uh it's very very crazy i don't know
it's tough to there's not many people
that have you can even talk to him about
it you know
because it [ __ ] you up a little like it
makes you like uh
not trust people and [ __ ] for a while
like in what way
i don't know i don't know how to explain
it it's
but back to the main the experience of
it was like
you just uh it was kind of surreal
because i went from i was one of the
first people to get like
cancelled or however you want to say
consequences
however yeah however you want to say it
doesn't matter what we call it it is
what it is right but uh
i was one of the first people to go from
i was doing i was poor
i was not famous at all i was poor and
then i got cancelled immediately
like that was my like right it was a
very different
yeah you got canceled on the way i got
canceled immediately
yeah they they literally were like how
about this guy and everyone was like no
so you got cast on snl yes and then what
happened
um so i found out i was getting on snl
the day before they announced it they
got a call they're like hey we want to
put you on the cast
the whole time i was we'll start from
the top
my my agents and all those people they
were like
you're do you want to audit or do you
want to write do you want to send a
packet in
for snl and i was like no i'm not going
to be a writer i'm never going to
i won't work on that show and then i
guess they saw me at jfl
and comedy central thing and they were
like we like him we want him to audition
he can come straight in to audition
so i went straight to the main stage for
the audition and the whole time leading
up to it i was like i'm not
i'm never going to get this i don't care
i want to do stand-up
i kind of hated snl at that point
because every
every sketch was like you know you know
what it is
yeah and then i was like i'll never fit
in there
and then when when you go to audition
it's just you just wait
your turn in a green room and they keep
you there extra long for like two or
three hours
to like make you nervous really but i
knew i was certain i was never gonna get
it
and i really wasn't nervous i was in
there [ __ ] dipping
hanging out and then they were like
alright it's your turn to go
but that's when the nerves hit like you
walk in and you see the main stage
because that's what you audition on is
like the stage wow and it's a totally
empty studio the whole room's empty
except for a table of like writers
and producers and lorne michaels and
then you go on and they're like three
two go do five minutes wow in front of
just a camera right and are you doing
stand up
i did stand up wow i did five minutes of
stand up that's all
and then uh i ran into michael che that
night
and i was like i was so nervous like i
was so nervous when i was auditioning
that i had to like hold the mic against
my chin
because my hand was [ __ ] shaking it
was crazy there's no one in the room
you just have to do stand up for five
minutes to no one that's so weird it was
so weird and
you're not supposed to look at or
acknowledge the table of writers and
producers or whatever
why they have rules they have rule they
have rules that your agents tell you
they never told you any rules so your
agent says do not look at the writers
yeah they're like don't even acknowledge
them pretend the room's full
just go and everybody was like they're
never gonna laugh the table
lauren all them they're not gonna laugh
first thing i said they all started
laughing and i was like
i was supposed to not acknowledge him
but you know i was doing standards do
you remember what you said
no i don't genuinely he just
just did a bit yeah i was just yeah i
was nervous
uh but as soon as they started laughing
i was like and then i went back to you
know what i mean i was like looking at
them
i could see they were laughing and you i
was told the whole time no one's gonna
laugh
they were laughing and i was like oh
[ __ ] i did pretty good ran into che that
night i was like i
sucked i was nervous he was like no you
were that was good
then a couple days later you get a call
back and you go into the office and you
meet everybody and you walk around and
talk to everybody
and the people i was with that were also
doing that then you go into lauren
michael's office
to meet him so the three people i was
with
they all went in slowly met him
left one guy didn't even get invited in
they just sent him home
which is [ __ ] up they invited him to
the call back and then we're like
no never mind wow and then they kept me
there for an extra like
hour by myself and i was just sitting
there like oh [ __ ] i got this
like i'm gonna be on it like this is i
can't believe i got this
i wasn't even excited i was just like
this is wild
this is [ __ ] nuts and then i go in
and meet with lauren and he's
he's the man he's a nice guy and he was
like i'm gonna use you
but i don't know how and like all that
[ __ ] and then
time passes and i figured they were
gonna ask me to be a writer
because that's usually how it goes yeah
usually you work on the show to
experience what the show's like but
i don't know i didn't want to be a
writer by all accounts that place is a
den of things
everybody yeah a den of thieves
you hear jim brewer's account of the the
climate in that place yeah and it's
horrific
yeah they're all stealing from writers
they're stealing from performers
if you're a writer and you submit your
packages the the
riders will steal your [ __ ] according to
brewer yeah
if you submit a package they own that
package even if they don't hire you
i know that so if you have some great
premises they decide they're just going
to take your premises and not hire you
they
they own all those bits yeah it's crazy
i mean yeah i don't i don't i don't i
don't care about writing
i didn't want to be a writer right so i
was like if even if they offered me the
writing thing
i was like i don't want to take it i
think i would have at the time
but anyway they they asked me to go
straight to cast
so i was like yeah i'll definitely do
that
lauren calls says hey we want to use you
on the show
we're going to announce it tomorrow he
was like do you have anything uh
you want us to check out like they have
people that vet you
right but they they're not used to
people having podcasts right so they'd
have to go through hundreds
they go through your facebook your
instagram your twitter
i was just like i'll just delete all
that [ __ ] i don't care delete it at all
right but i was like i also have a
podcast and they're like yeah what's
that and i was like i don't know i say
like
gay and [ __ ] a lot and they were like
they're like oh that's fine don't worry
about it
[Laughter]
so i was like all right we'll see and uh
so the day they announced it it's a it
was it was cool it was very cool you
hear from everybody you've ever grown up
with they're all like holy [ __ ]
what just like i can't believe you're on
this and then so that lasted for about
like
three hours before an article came out
that was like here's what this guy
says there's a clip of me saying
something
you know unsavory stuff yeah but
talking [ __ ] it was it was the one
podcast we ever filmed that's the one
they used
wow and it just happened and it was
funny too because people like man they
really had to dig to find this i was
like that's probably like three minutes
in
it's like we had one podcast online it
was three minutes in
it's what we were saying earlier that's
what podcasts are and that's what comics
do a lot we talk [ __ ] it doesn't mean
you really mean those things but the
idea today is that
talking [ __ ] is not real they want to
take
out of context phrases and sentences
that you've used and put them in quotes
and make you look like a monster yeah
yeah for sure
it was only one article that came out no
there was
quite a few so many articles i was i
think i was number one on twitter for
like three straight days
wow i'm just getting [ __ ] eviscerated
did you read it all
oh i read all of it oh no yeah everybody
was like stop reading
i still read comments i read every
comment why i don't know
oh it's [ __ ] up and it's crazy too
because i'll read like
90 good ones and then one bad one one
bad one will [ __ ] you up
just depends which one it is right you
know i'll get called like uh
you know fat [ __ ] constantly i'll be
like yeah whatever i can i can walk
through that no problem
right but then there will be one that's
like he's
like something something where they get
you where they they know you
yeah like he laughs at his own jokes on
every podcast it's like oh
[ __ ] do i [ __ ] right
anyway so i get all that stuff comes out
and it was funny this is funny i went
into lauren's
lauren michael's office and he was
talking and i was convinced i was
getting fired like i knew i was getting
fired
because if they didn't get me on that
there's so much more
so much worse and uh
so he was talking to me and he was like
no we think we can
he's like if we just get you to the
first episode like people will see
you're not a piece of [ __ ]
person right just talk and i was like
whatever i'll do
if i just if i get fired here whatever
i'll just go do joe rogan next week and
i'll be fine
anyway i thought that was funny no what
i was like i i
literally thought i literally thought
that oh okay yeah i thought it would be
funny
well it could have been funny yeah i was
booked up though no it's fine
it was just funny to truly that was a
conversation i actually had really
in lorne michael's office in the middle
of that that's hilarious
it was i was in pure [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah but
because i remember somebody contacted me
like to have you on
and i was like i don't have any room
like for a while i could do like an
emergency podcast but i'm like let me
let this dude ride this out yeah
and then we'll do one eventually truly
glad that that did not happen
because i would have come in emotional
yeah come in like guns
and i never felt that way like the whole
time i was like i kind of get it when
someone gets really canceled you need
perspective
yeah you need you know what it's like
it's like you need that venom to work
its way through your system
and then you develop a certain amount of
immunity to
the actual moment yeah
absolutely yeah yeah it ended up being a
good thing so when lauren pulls you in
the office and says we just have to get
you to the stage we just have to get you
to an episode
then what happens it just it just kept
it just kept steamrolling like it never
it didn't dissipate at all like it kept
being like no you guys need to fire him
and i get it because well that's where
the fun is
yeah the fun and going after someone is
not going after someone and then no
consequences
that makes them sad yeah which makes
them happy
so they can get you fired yeah and
that's yeah they did
they did a good job yeah good job and
it's fine look
the whole time here's why it's fine your
sketches that you're doing
what is it gillian keeves yeah those are
the best [ __ ] comedy sketches that
are on the internet right now
thank you i'm not bullshitting the only
thing that's at the same level is kyle
dunnigan [ __ ]
kyle down again the [ __ ] that he's doing
dude because he's got a
massive advantage with that face swap
though and he's so good at it he's an
impression
he's amazing his have you seen the new
thing that dunnigan is doing he's
the the [ __ ] what is it he does a
fresh prince
take off with biden what is it called
yeah fresh prince of dc
yeah something fresh something like that
fresh prez yeah dude
it's it's tear jerking his bill
oh my god it's incredible new rule yeah
it just
oh my god and it's there's something
about it that it's almost got like a
south park
s quality to it because it looks so fake
but it's obvious it's like it's like
these things
like look how bad these look look at the
little tiny hand he holds up for bill
maher
like the face swap thing is amazing
it really is amazing because he's like
look at
aoc because it looks so fake like you
would never believe that that's the real
person
so it's comedic but it it's also
the the material is brilliant and you
can get away with so much in someone
else's voice
when everybody knows it's not really
that person yeah it's really one of the
most genius platforms ever created yeah
and he's the master
him and him and kurt metzger kurt is
they're incredible they're they're both
yeah it's the best [ __ ] kurt's like one
of my he's one of my favorite
but the [ __ ] you're doing is right up
there with that it's really [ __ ]
funny man it's really funny and it's
like something you would never be able
to do on snl
the stuff you guys are doing how are you
financing this stuff
uh i financed half and then we had a
production company that financed half
the trump one was made the trump speed
dating
yeah it's john mcever he's keeves he's
incredible writer he writes all he's
added some
makes him he's they're really good man
yeah they're really good
damn i spazzed on that snl story no you
didn't at all
how do you feel like it came out bad no
no no look it's an awkward story
it is yeah but it's always here's what's
uncomfortable about it is i don't want
to sound like
it's weird for me to rail against cancel
culture because i was
a victim of it for lack of a better word
you know what i mean why is it weird
for you to rail against i don't know i
don't know i just it makes
peace it seems defensive yeah yeah i'd
rather just be like look
if people bring up cancel culture i'm
just like honestly
i really believe it's better for you in
the long run i really do you're a
brilliant comedian and i think your
sketches are incredible and i think it's
better that you not get attached to
something that's ultimately corrupting
and i don't want to be on the other side
of it where it's like
i'm a free speech guy i'm a [ __ ] it's
like dude i don't want to be involved in
any of this i
just want to do comedy catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience